I have the perfect reason for you to
start TRT I'm glad I'm a number one
reason to what go to my Instagram chin
and bring up what's-his-name
how about so glad you brought this
episode it was a it was a fake I
shouldn't tell you how many communes
have text me go dude do you think he's
on stuff I went excuse me Tom about the
guy who's best friends with Batista but
first of all look at his [ __ ] arms
and I mean look at the veins yeah who is
he playing that he's the Shred he's
Amaro he's a Marvel kick he's got a
great body phenomenal I mean I would
never have thought that guy I think
people are they think I'm hating them
I'm not hating on I think it's so dope
I'm saying I'll take whatever whatever
program he's on all he's got a great
frame that's a fantastic body I would
love to be built like that well he was
born like this frames not good and
wasn't born with oh that's a good frame
no you know what I'm saying though he's
got a lot to work with
no go to before-and-afters no he was a
super nerdy Silicon Valley yeah but I'm
saying his ability to put on muscle like
that is pretty impressive I'm going did
they have his work out on their chin
yeah it was a part of getting once I
want to look like that how yet he
reveals how yet redic ridiculously
shredded what's he say he probably never
lifted weights in his life either looked
like when he was doing that ceiling
skinny
I mean thin nerdy dude it's my shoulders
see where his shoulders look huge not
the bulk of you know here's the thing
though amazing even couldn't look better
couldn't look phenomenal
he looks goddamn happy with four arms I
mean see the sexist India in the world
now I think so that's him as Bryan
Callen yeah you him prey of some figures
what's he say would he do did you see
what he did I'm not sure I feel like I
did a [ __ ] a lot of a stack of gold Jim
Stewart no he said he he has a resources
like trainers if they have Teesta huh
yeah obviously he did a Matisse are like
really good friends yeah probably the
best friends yeah one oh yeah I see well
no you're not gonna
unless you say it's not like that yeah I
mean he probably put in it I don't know
nothing happy there's a ton of work yeah
but a lot of hard work a hard time to go
from what he was on Silicon Valley to a
Marvel [ __ ] superhero in a year
dang that's is so nice I'm sewing for me
too
I celebrate I think people thought when
I pose I'm hate no no oh my god for that
without shutting down my my natural
testosterone production the side effects
I don't know he's so worried about that
shouldn't I be well we could all the
guys you know little [ __ ] you hang out
with all those guys around they seem
fine yeah yeah there you could tuck this
much Sloan right now I'm getting on it
this is the craziest transformation
right that I've ever seen anybody else
and also by the way he's working out the
right way he's got somebody knows what
the [ __ ] they're doing
maybe well he said Marvel's paying for
it too so yeah whoo biggest studio ever
to pay for all the stuff yeah and
there's big boys but but again who would
hate on this guy cuz hey you know if
Marvel calls ikt once you be the next
spider-man you got put on 30 pounds of
muscle you have a year you have
unlimited budget I'm going nuts
of course I am I'd be all over it I'm
try can you think of anybody else that's
made that big of a transformation uh
well Ryan Reynolds did for a while did
ya girls off you guys in was it two to
two girls there to play so it was yummy
and then he got on ER t v-- on TR tube
for sure T on testosterone for blade
Trinity that's tooth unhurt in fact I
think he's a little chubby kid when he
was younger he go know he had a soul
patch yeah yeah mitts back in the day
you know mm-hmm
always funny though always had a sense
of humor really really funny yeah really
funny
he's just skinny there but yeah he got
jacked I'm trying to think who else the
Hugh Jackman got my man and older he's
older - Hugh Jackman for Wolverine yeah
but your Wolverine oh who had a huge
transformation John Travolta
Saturday Night Live three or whatever
the [ __ ] check him out John three
there's a huge transformation he went
from being uh what the [ __ ] it is I
don't know if that's a good example I
was one just like skinny though no no it
was pretty good like if you see him fat
like that yeah he's there and then okay
but some skinny he's young but he went
from they showed his body there and they
showed him before that what she was so
fat well he was younger yeah yeah yeah
weird
Stallone Travolta look at back in the
eighties when it was cool to have a
headband and a tank top I hear some
balls were in a headband on the front
cover of Saturday Night Fever he has
them it was the trio Will Smith for uh
Muhammad Ali got jacked
oh yeah holiday feel from Fresh Prince
to Muhammad Ali
yes Smith he was jacked yep yes he was I
can't think of it best but as far as
this do come from Silicon Valley to
Marvel superhero you're making a good
point it might be the best I've never
seen I was shocked I was I literally
thought it was a oh oh the dude from
dress apart the guy from Gardens a
galaxy Oh Chris Pratt yeah Chris Pratt
man he was using me I think he wrestled
in college so he was a but he got fat
and then he got you he was fat but even
that body's not it's nothing near what
kumail's body was by natural to whose
natural oh that's [ __ ] who she says
natural Pratt no no no Jake no Jake
Gyllenhaal but he's like I don't know
that's super impressed Tom Hardy for
being that's true Steve Rogers skinny
guy all right just didn't eat carbs
that's me Tom Hardy for Bronson where
Tom Harkin Tom Hardy for you did warrior
oh my god hold on that was him in the
mechanic look at how crazy he is how did
he get down the machinery the machinist
he's a crazy person that's why he's a
crazy person I think he said that he ate
and
Apple and like a can of tuna and that's
it look at him he's a [ __ ] afterwards
dude he went from 180 220 pounds then
boss kept at 220
holy [ __ ] keep going down chin so
fascinating yeah Bradley Boyer and
Bradley's always been pretty muscular oh
that's what he was gay look at him dude
I'm Christian Bale hands down I don't
know how he's that good discipline is
insane I had insane I don't know what
he's got the discipline
hated he said he goes I don't I resent
the fact that I he he said I've I've
always been ashamed at being somebody
who put makeup on and made believe so I
have to make it hard on myself
makes sense Drake wha
Nick Jonas you did you look small
thoroughly smart or respect as much in
Troy brother I father sure he's a nice
guy
Jonas is bigger now I don't like real
skinny Jonas and it's healthier for him
but I cumin between if it's better than
for sure the last candy man it's way
funnier on the left is a disaster it's
such a good actor though I love Kevin
Kevin was always muscular always a small
small shredded big deal
I don't know what's gonna just always
been fat so this is a terror another
running of ideas yeah this again just
always been thick they're just a party
that lost weight now that's that yeah I
rented Wow
he's sir I mean Jimmy Kimmel was Michael
Moore's fat and fat Jimmy Kimmel lost a
lot of weight though yeah I did a lot of
weight looks good
handsome it I thought Joey Diaz was
almost 400 pounds like 2 or 280 now I
think 270 280 I'm looking forward to
getting ridiculous ridiculous I mean I
can't wait to go on T everybody's on TR
t except for me
I'm the only [ __ ] person but you
couldn't do it on the Goldbergs or off
with all that good I look great does
that no be weird your character he's
just like real he's a gym teacher
you have to write in this he talks about
being jacked I know we can't just show
up yeah you have to tell what you're
doing yeah be weird you can go on some
morlun which produces your body produces
natural some orleans no that's not gonna
work for you dude it's gone now you like
cough syrup [ __ ] and then get on HGH
and steroids Brian there's nothing you
can get on I don't know what your
trainer Rudy or whether [ __ ] you there's
nothing intake that's gonna boost that
stuff I've gotta take up yep cool it's
gonna do nothing for you at your age you
need hd8 talk to specialists alone take
HGH and a shitload of deca dude and shut
the [ __ ] not deca dude don't make me
take deca dude you don't want that you
want to be jacked enough but you don't
want that cuz I you won't be like
tomorrow I'm going out here and then
we're gonna have a problem plus that
plus I'm doing jujitsu and boxing you
know what I'm saying be cool but you
know what I'm saying I don't when you
push me and then I get froggy and then
it becomes a whole disaster right and
then you got your hands full
I'm not saying you don't beat me it be
so you guys look at me it'd be CGI ants
fall right it would be you with Rory I'm
not done hey then you got your hands
full right maybe even later up what I'm
telling me dude I'm talking he got hands
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]